was that musically that just to do a
musically hi welcome to this video my
name is fair topic if you didn't know
now you know your life is different now
you see the title of this video
August favorites I'm gonna talk to you
about things that I've enjoyed during
the month of August slightly more than
other things let's do it yeah yes yeah
yes yeah yes yeah this is Nyx's NY X's
two-timer this is an eyeliner that has a
pencil eyeliner and a liquid liner all
in one convenient stick that's a liquid
liner and that's a pencil liner Club
novelty I love stick
I love convenience it's mostly why I
love making confetti cake in the comfort
of my own home and this product is all
of that
I like the Islanders that are involved
in this product and I like that it is
one product boasting two different
experiences which in a way is kind of
very representative of my favorites
videos where they both education or
information but they really are just so
stupid next yeah yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey two-faced perfect lips lip liner in
the color perfect spice and in a rare
occasion in my favorites videos I'm
actually wearing this product on my lips
right now look at that I think it's
pretty
urban spice feels like that's the
original spice girls name that Victoria
Beckham pitched for herself
in the first ever like Spice Girls
naming meeting when they were like we
all need to come up with names and they
were like ginger totally get it sporty
absolutely baby spice
oh that's adorable and then she was like
perfect spice and they were like okay
wait let's um let's slow it down a
second regardless this is a lip liner
and I really like it very much so cool
yeah yeah yeah yeah this has very likely
been in a favorites video of mine before
but this is fan or balm or however you
want to say it ba ends total refresh
cooling and body cloths there you go now
you can see all of it perfectly there
hagh cooling body cloths so I guess
they're supposed to bring your body
temperature down but to me these are
just tiny to go showers I use these to
wipe all of the crevices when I know I
need to be in kind of a social situation
and my hygiene is um less than part you
Tran I'm putting these in my car
in my purse or backpack or whatever just
like making these readily available
because I don't shower they're very mild
which I like so you don't smell like
overcompensation you just smell like oh
you're just normally hygienic when they
have no idea next
yeah if the yeah yeah okay I see it oops
Kate Somerville's gently daily wash hey
Somerville is a really great line of
skincare products and they tend to be a
little expensive I like to go on Sephora
calm and order the travel size or the
value pack versions of the products and
I worked for the first time Kate
Somerville gently Kunik Kate Somerville
gentle daily wash and I really like it
it's just kind of a normal face wash you
can use it daily but the best part of
this
I love novelty so much and this has it
lots of face washes and like travel or
Latrese come in this sort of form that
looks like package they twist the top
off of when you are in a shower
sometimes that's like difficult to do if
there's soap and things this I don't
even see that see this hole right here
all you do with this is you twist it
like that and now this is opened and you
can squeeze it directly into your hand
then you can just twist it back up like
nothing ever happened
you can with one hand operate this
entire thing this seems so dumb and so
like common sense but I've never had
another product especially like a
product that I would use in the shower
have that novelty or like accessibility
so big fan next yeah yes see any LCIF
via this I got is a free gift with a
large Sephora purchase know sometimes
you black out and then you come to and
you realize that you just ordered
everything off of the internet and you
feel like a monster of consumerism so
for
does a really great job of like gently
stroking all of that pain away by giving
you free gifts with large orders and
this is one of the free gifts I got it
just it's a scent this is Stella
McCartney's pop I like it very much my
scent that I've been wearing for like
two years is this
it's Elizabeth and James Nirvana black
and I love it because it's at a slightly
like musky er more masculine vibe to it
dry and joy I don't like smelling like
hotel soap which I think a lot of
perfume smell like but Stella
McCartney's pop does it it um oh I got
it everywhere it just got it everywhere
I'm awful at describing sense no just
smells like a fun hot air balloon you
know that scent I'm the website it says
the notes are tomato leaves violet
leaves and green mandarin violet to bros
plumeria sandalwood cedar wood Musk's
those are all the notes according to
Sephora calm my only notice doesn't
smush a cool neck yeah yeah say yeah
yeah say this is another scent not
necessarily for your body this is 40
spaces I recently went to this kind of
like health and wellness spa hotel
situation with my mom and the last day
that we were there we went to like there
I guess gift shop sort of thing and I'm
quoting it it was just it was a gift
shop and I bought this this is a
eucalyptus spray it's called Sonoma
eucalyptus whatever that means and it's
a eucalyptus oil spray people if this is
supposed to help open your sinuses so
you can spray on your pillow or in rooms
to get rid of stale air it's kind of
just like a refresher sprite it makes
your house smell cleaner than it is like
deodorant for your home yeah can you see
okay so you can see can't see it I mean
you can't see it seven thirty thirty
film dirty thirty that Hannah and mamrie
and I are executive producers of and in
with a bunch of other amazing people
it's coming out in less than a month I'm
getting anxious because it's no I wasn't
anxious I just had thirty thirty is
coming out on September 23rd which is so
exciting and if you go to a dirty thirty
movie calm you can pre-order
all different packages that include the
movie and a variety of other things or
like if you saw the video
posted on Friday watch if you didn't see
it God did you have a chance to see 30
30 in an actual movie theater if you go
to dirty 30 movie calm you can go and
RSVP'd if you live near any of the major
cities that are listed on the website
and if those major cities get over a
certain number of RSVPs they will show
30 30 in a movie theater in that city
and I'm so excited that my shoulders are
up here now so just quickly please
pre-order dirty city movie calm it's
such a wonderful evolution from Camp
Takota
and I think you guys will really really
enjoy it this is awesome this is gifted
to me by Meghan Mattoon who is an
amazing youtuber super stylish action
blogger she's just awesome I got a
chance to be in a video with her on a
show a series that she does on her
YouTube channel called the right now
show which was super fun I'll put a link
in the description of the episode that
we did and as a gif of her show she gave
me this this is my dog goose and it says
shorty get goose and she made this like
she's also a graphic designer because
apparently like sometimes God does like
oh you should have all of the skills she
has all of the skills she'd made this
like from her brain with a computer and
it's so [ __ ] awesome and I think she
is absolutely amazing so please go check
out Meghan Mattoon YouTube channel when
people are like good at things it is
very inspiring okay that's it through my
favorites of the month of August I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
enjoy this or if you just like hated
this violently please subscribe to my
youtube channel we've passed three
million subscribers everything feels
exciting so I'd love for you to stick
around let me know what you guys have
been like you miss month
and I don't know